hey what's up guys my name is Ayana and
welcome to episode 11 of network chat
programming ok so I want to be making a
few changes here it's kind of taken a
while alright I want to be honest it was
supposed to be a small series and we're
actually focusing more on GUI than on
networking and that was the whole idea
to focus on networking someone cut down
a GUI a bit ok we have this issue right
now that if we drag you can see this
massive white space here that's actually
gray I'm not going to bother fixing that
completely I'm going to slightly fix it
ok the way that I'm going to slightly
fix it is I'm simply just going to get
rid of it so what we have is you can see
here on our scroll which is our text
area which is our massive history a
little text area we start a grid
coordinate one well I'm going to shift
that back to zero on the X and the y and
what I want to do is I want to make the
grid width 3 so I'm upping it by a bit
so essentially what I'm doing is I'm
moving it left and extending it a bit
and I'm also going to change the grid
height here to two okay
so I'm adding 1 because this is 1 by
default that's why I had to add it I'm
adding 1 to each of these two and I'm
subtracting 1 from each of these pretty
simple so if I launch it now what you
should see is something that's not
really too different ok but and you can
see it looks well the same but if I try
and resize it now you can see it's
actually gonna resize with it now we do
have some other problems again namely
the only problem we actually have to
worry about is the fact that if we drag
up the text field as you can see
disappears and I'm not going to cover
that today when I cover that another
time in more of an aesthetical thing now
also you can say that we have this text
box
this text field problem here if I just
move this up so you guys can see
properly we have this text box problem
here and that of course is because we
haven't shifted that across either like
we did with our text area so if we go
down to our text message which is right
over here and where are we yeah right
over here I'll actually just copy this
here and set the the width to be true
and shift the grid X what was called so
i grid with to be 2 and I'll shift grid
X to - what - you know I'll subtract
by one making it zero here and if we
launch this now what we should say is if
I resize this you can see it kind of
stays with it okay and that doesn't
change and that's good okay that's a
good start here that's all we're going
to do with gy right now because again as
I said this is turning into more of a
how to make sure your eyes with Java
which is not the absolute purpose of the
series at all okay so let's start on
networking finally right I'm not going
to cut you off from there like so you
loose time no we're going to start
networking right now because this needs
to be done now there's going to be a
method here and now I'm not I'm not 100%
happy with the way the clients laid out
right now this is more of a GUI class
but whatever I'll still keep it this way
what I will do is I'll actually just
make a method here private method called
it'll be void in fact it can be bullying
because I'm ignorant and false I'm just
thinking if we should yeah okay we'll
keep a boolean here so open connection
all right now it's going to need some
parameters it's going to need an address
which is a string it's going to need a
well it's definitely an address it's
definitely gonna need a port and ID and
name not really yeah okay so we go up
over here we will actually run this open
connection method here with the
parameter address and the integer port
now when we do up in this connection
this is a balloon so the whole purpose
of making this of bullying is that we
can then handle if it works or not
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
assign a boolean connect essentially to
the open connection so what is that
going to do right [ __ ] for those of you
who are confused by this well this is
doing is is running this method here
grabbing the return value and assigning
it to connect okay so we're still
running the method as if it as if it was
used as if it was just a normal void
method if we get rid of that it's just
going to run the method but as you can
see it's not return or it's not
returning sorry it's not assigning that
return value to anything they're just
disappearing but here we're actually
assigning it to a variable so then what
that enables us to do is say that okay
if we return false you know ideally
we'll implement here an open connection
that if false is returned you
if it fails an opening a connection will
return false so what we can do here is
say something like if you know if
connected and work out right so if
Connect is false then we can kind of
return and don't bother creating a
window or whatever or in fact better yet
actually create a window but you know
say something like you know we'll just
print out an arrow for now it says um
you know connection failed connection
failed and we'll also append that system
there and also append that to the
console by typing console and then
whoops console and then our text over
here now this this this method is more
of like a C way of handling things to be
honest like this this boolean stuff
because Java does has a Java does have
Java does have you know exception
handling built-in like trying caps and
stuff but occasionally you know
something like this might be useful and
might look really nice as it does in
this case okay so again up to you if you
use it a lot but it is a good suggestion
so how do we open the connection right
how do we actually get Java to connect
to a computer that is not this computer
how do we get it to actually branch out
and access the network and the
networking hardware now we're going to
need a few classes for this right
the primary class that we're going to
use for the client will be a socket okay
now that's obvious right a socket a soft
what is a socket think of a socket is
literally like a power outlet right in
order to access power you have to
connect to that socket in Java or in
programming in order to well in
networking actually in order to connect
to the network we need to actually
connect the socket and I use the term
networking a very broad form I realized
that if you're doing actual like IT
networking you probably wouldn't even
use the word socket very often you
probably use well you use other words
but um the point is a socket is
essentially your entrance into the
network so we need to create a socket
now this is where we decide if we want
to use what what protocol we want to use
okay there are two main protocols that
we can use for actually transferring
data sending packets in between two
clients on that
two devices on a network so the first
one is TCP now that's the transmission
control protocol I'm pretty sure the
benefits of that I'm going to make an
in-depth episode on this I'm pretty sure
I'm actually going to do that because
it's a really in-depth topic but
basically TCP actually guarantees
delivery of packets okay because what
happens is once and a packet by the way
is just a bunch of data just a bunch of
bytes that we can then our you know
dollar we're just having data it's
called a packet so TCP if we actually
send a packet of data you know using the
TCP protocol what happens is when the
receiving end actually receives that
packet it actually sends a reply being
like I've got it I've received it and
that way you'll guarantee that your
delivery will be actually you know if
the delay will actually get delivered it
won't get lost on the way and the other
thing that the guarantees is actual on
sequential delivery well let's come to
the sequential delivery but once it
receives a bunch of Packers it actually
orders them into the actual order that
they were supposed to be get sent in so
as you can imagine TCP is good for you
know areas where data is very important
now because I actually I should probably
go for the other protocol first UDP
that's a you use a Datagram protocol I
think is it user yeah I think it's user
Datagram protocol checks payable out
though basically that is the opposite of
TCP in a way okay it doesn't care if
packets get there or not and the other
thing it doesn't care this is one thing
I should mention TCP has to establish a
connection before it sends packets it
can't just send packets to an address it
has to establish a connection with that
address first all that device first UDP
does not you can just send a packet to
192.168.1.1 hundred which you might not
have a device connected to that um to
that IP address and you know you with
using you UDP like it the protocol
wouldn't care if it actually gets their
own they'll just send it
TCP you can't just send it to that IP
address you have to actually establish a
connection first there's something
called a three-way handshake not going
to get into that stuff that's pretty
advanced networking stuff all you need
to know is that ACP requires a
connection at all times and will
acknowledge where the packets are
received or not UDP
doesn't care you can imagine straight
away now that UDP is used
things like games because sometimes you
know you temporarily lose connection to
the server and that's not a big deal
okay the other problem is TCP will
resend packets that do not get there
okay if your network times out for a few
set for two seconds TCP will actually
resend those packets that were not
received by you as a result of that
network timeout because of that you'll
be two seconds behind in the game okay
that's a bit of an issue that's why UDP
you know you timeout for two seconds you
don't receive data at all and then you
start receiving the most up-to-date data
when you get your connection back online
that's why UDP is good for games okay
that was a very quick up a very very
quick explanation hope you guys got that
but the idea here is that we're going to
be using UDP for this now for this chat
program is that the best idea probably
not probably not because what happens is
if we do lose the connection will
actually never get that message that was
sent um but because this is a lead up to
game programming we are going to use UDP
okay I might do a TCP version of this
later probably not but we'll see so what
we needed two classes okay one class
really that will actually handle the
connection and that is a Datagram socket
now user Datagram protocol is what UDP
sense also that's why we use a Datagram
if we were using a TCP we just use
socket okay this is a class in Java
called socket and that handles TCP
connections not serve a socket service
locket is the quad the server side so
private diagram socket socket can call
whatever you like and call socket
because it's it's our socket it's our
connection the other class we're going
to actually need less and put that class
quickly by hitting command shift or
occurs on my map or control shift on
Windows private init address address so
what isn't in it I'm Annette Andrew I
don't know how to pronounce that okay
let's call it um in that address oh
let's just call it it'll essentially be
our IP address and it'll call it I pay
here now what is it what is this
Annette address thing um save job can
give a better explanation than I can
well look at that
exactly I thought it might be this
simple it's it's it's an IP address okay
I I thought some reason I figured the
job
elaborate explanation but now it just
has it's an IP address which of course
it is okay is my it is an IP address now
what do we use the inner address for
this IP address for we actually use it
for destiny our location of packets so
in other words if we want to set a
packet to a particular address we use
this init address thing and the reason
we use this and not just a string is
because socket accepts this and not a
string okay so back into here we've got
this we've got our up here our IP
address as a string here right we need
to convert it to an inert dress to this
IP address object essentially so how do
we do that well luckily it's very very
simple okay
all we need to do is actually set IP
here which is referring to this - this
is a static method here in it address
dot get by name and then our address
which is our string
well string which is right there okay
cool
now when you try and catch this probably
throw our unknown host exception yep
which is in case we enter something like
Cherno as the as the IP address that's
clearly not not in my P address so we do
have to handle stuff like that now what
else so out of the port of course we
also need the port and I'll tell you why
actually we don't really need the port
for the client do we
we'll talk about that a bit more a bit a
bit later because it is quite a topic so
we also set the socket equal to new data
Gramm socket okay sweet of course that's
a lowercase G right we also need to add
this to our cache clauses soccer
exception now if we do get any of these
exceptions something's gone wrong and
essentially well it's a problem so what
we want to do here is we can print the
sack race that's fine but we want to
return false okay and we want to do the
same thing here now here's a quick trick
that might help you guys out a bit and
that is no I surely not measure that
here I was going to mention error
handling but that's that's quite off
topic we'll deal with that later though
so yeah and then if everything goes
right we'll just recommend true at the
end of this okay now
that's pretty much it right that is a
that's pretty much it now why do we need
stuff like the address for example like
we haven't used it right now why do we
even need that and the reason we need
that is because when we do actually send
data we'll need this address and just
basically a good a good I guess place to
convert it into an IMS in s probably
Eyre addresses from the hey pronounce it
but the good way to actually convert
this string into an official IP address
is probably in the opening connection
thing and then eventually when we met
when we write our send method which is
over here but when we actually send it
over the network we will will actually
use this ina address and one cycle and
line and address to actually send a
graph of animal so you use a port that
okay so we don't need this in fact we
put in this this could be done somewhere
else did not think this one through did
I um doesn't matter I might add more
stuff into here later okay
anyway thanks for watching guys that is
how we open a connection I know we
haven't done anything major yet but our
next video episode 12 we're going to
cover sending data over a network and
the one after that probably receiving
and then we'll move on to server stuff
and that's really it like this is a
pretty simple application here it's
really not that difficult but if you did
enjoy the video place the like button
let's go to 200 likes for one video per
day 300 likes for two videos per day
let's give this series over and done
with so make sure you do hit the like
button if you did enjoy the video and
I'll see you guys next time good bye
you